hello and welcome to this video anttila
until at all is the opponent so another
black game here in the exchange
variation let's see what aunty is up to
the funky sideline and white white is
not trying to really do all that much
that that's interesting taking with the
night en dispersion I have this doll
right that shouldn't be all that bad
should be a decent version of other
lines so if I trade here if I trade here
he's got the D file it's probably not
that grade I it's not a big deal but
it's not a big deal i think we treat
this it's probably just not great on c4
anyway now i hope the age i was thinking
but he might play 95 or Bishop f4
actually yes okay okay okay so this
isn't all that great him anyway normally
in those positions you have a pawn on f6
which is not the case here it should
help a little bit I wonder if I'm
actually threatening to take on it for
maybe I am maybe I am
yeah can I take you it looks very risky
I currently don't see why what is the
thing here
I'm probably getting chick made to do
yeah just don't see it I just don't see
why I mean I know that I'm not just
winning a pawn but I wonder why I
shouldn't do it yeah but this is this
isn't all that all that convincing is it
well just go back what's the deal well
I'm gonna look I'm not losing or
something so okay I see but what if I
just go to c6 check so I did take that
pawn and I don't really see how he
punishes me for it not too bad does he
want to go G for you don't think that
this is actually that big a deal ok so
let's do this gain some space mm-hmm
just wonder how do i coordinate this
this best I can play Bishop g5 at some
point and yeah but it's not a good idea
right to take ever there Bishop d6 gets
opposite colored bishops that's
definitely a wrong idea I can I can just
just advance him cannot be all that bad
looks a little bit like a girl in Ward
ending up where where where somehow
we're somehow the e5 pawn is missing
yeah here I can't go g5 I don't know
let's do it that's an idea that I had
seen earlier ticks and age five maybe
Bishop b5 can be a tricky and it's
probably true okay so let's start with
this
so that I have worked to g8 at least and
have not to bother with Knight f6 not
sure how good g5 was to be honest now
that I see this in the light of day I
don't know h5 this g5 I probably have to
do that it's difficult to to to to do it
to do this without the h-bomb being
under constant on pressure from the from
the bishop on a form h5 could be weak
a night at five that's something that I
should have paid attention to know at
least he doesn't play it I'm not sure
about about it about it okay trading one
rookies helpful and I'll see if I can do
something with the bishop so here what
training is wrong but I'm in some sort
of pin right he's a onsie to win oh and
who what why is rook e8 not winning
stuff what is the trick here I don't see
it that was the threat seems I'm winning
a PCM I don't see how he 96 no white
resides okay so that was a quite quick
turn of events yeah I was very cheeky
with taking this pawn there should be
six is a unconventional sideline but
it's not so bad okay so yeah and usually
they take with the Queen the engine just
wants to play Queen D 7 speed up
development I'm too much of a bishop
person I didn't want to give it up yeah
so we have a fairly standard ending here
the data that's definitely not bad for
white at all so he certainly is
perfectly okay here Knight f6 and Bishop
g5 yeah and well I took it and the
engine gives us as the best move yeah
okay one way for him is channel to do
this that's something that I felt is
possible
nice Knight f6 and c5 is hanging so yeah
the engine gives equal that's possible
those endings are check while I like
slight advantage over white those
endings can be tricky in the opposite
color I mean this is pretty strong I
have to poop 36 I think it's true it's
dry with the opposite coefficients okay
you did this and I think this is not
enough so rookie one more stronger now
let that make sense Kingda 76 really is
something that it shopping the grid
great deal and it's immediately
confirmed by the engine here black is
clearly better as pieces also don't do
all that much he had to play rook do you
wanna that's definitely compensation ok
and then is the interesting moment he
also watch this g5 yeah it's it's given
as the first choice by the computer so
it wasn't terrible and the h5 also makes
sense the H boys asics cannot
continuously BB babysitted by the rook
so takes and now rook the area it's a
good ending ever create but I think this
is also not bad oh how i blundered 9085
that's a funny tactic because of this ok
black is better because I can take seat
too but I didn't see any of that of
course the engine just wants to play da
it made me a bit nervous that this is
unprotected this is why I'm listed but
ok he doesn't have a good good square to
go gym here probably Bishop just moves
even here now yeah I'm very okay then
and here get that blundered the house
and 95 this is not such an easy tactic
for human players it's a bit uncommon
anyway that the rook wins stuff like
that so that's easily overlooked and we
both overlooked it so ok guys thanks for
watching